president biden is touting the nation's
latest jobs report the labor department
reported on friday that the economy
added 390 000 jobs
in may that keeps the unemployment rate
at a near 50-year low of 3.6 percent but
while the labor market remains robust
americans find themselves paying more
consumer prices were up more than 8
percent in april and gasoline prices are
going higher as well a year ago by as
much as 57
to 4.76 cents a gallon here to make
sense of all this economic data is cbs
news business analyst jill schlesinger
jill good morning good morning what are
the big takeaways from this well i think
this was a pretty strong report 390 000
jobs a little bit more than expected 3.6
it's just a tick above where we were
before covet started even the labor
force started to get a tiny bit bigger
but overall what we are going to be
seeing is i think over the course of
this year's job creation is going to
start tapering off last year we had more
than a half a million jobs a month this
year it's starting to slow down in the
last three months 408 000 a month on
average that's consistent with what we
would call a more normal labor market so
i think we'll get down to 200 000 or so
that would be okay we've still been
adding like 400 000 a month for it seems
like a long time even if that market
does tail off a little bit the bigger
question is when does inflation start to
tail off well i mean that's a big
question because we don't know we've
never been in a situation where the
federal reserve is chasing inflation
that has already appeared and this has
been 40 years in the making right so we
know that the fed has kept interest
rates really low for a long time we know
that demand has actually been pretty low
but here we are incredibly low for
incredibly low it's crazy and so when
you think about where we are right now
demand was soaring and supply was
constrained amid covid that's a recipe
for disaster a lot of economists believe
the feds started too late in their rate
hiking campaign we are where we are the
fed says they're going to be attacking
inflation we hope that that eight point
three percent rate drops down to maybe
four percent by the end of the year then
by next year it's two to three but guys
we are in uncharted territory we don't
know one of the things michelle
mentioned gas prices i know my husband
texted me from california over six
dollars a gallon there who sets that
price and do we expect to see it go down
anytime soon well you know it's supply
and demand and it's a global market and
so while we were seeing gas prices start
to come down the war in ukraine really
changed the situation russia supply so
much energy to europe and that has
actually conspired to have a spike in
energy prices across the board gang
there is not a lot anyone in the united
states can do to change this scenario so
what we are hopeful for is obviously an
end to the war in ukraine but i think we
are going to be contending with higher
inflation and higher gas prices for
quite some time the i word the the g
word so many so many concerns uh about
what could possibly land weight in terms
of a recession
what are what are your feelings uh i
think that we are very close to being at
a place where we'll know whether or not
the fed's policies are going to work or
not but remember what is the fed trying
to do they're tapping on the break to
slow down the economy it is possible
that they tap too hard they kind of push
too hard it screeches and we end up in a
recession ditch i don't want anyone to
think this is the worst thing in the
world we've had 13 recessions since
world war ii they're a normal part of
the economic cycle we don't like human
suffering but i think that most
economists think it's 50 50 will go into
a recession sometime next year it would
likely be a shallow one hopefully not a
lot of human suffering and i think it's
the longest we've ever had in between
recessions well it would be but for the
consecutive quarters of negative growth
well but for the covet recession which
actually did happen correct yes that
which is a weird one okay thank you
for so many
just a little bit
uh thank you for springing into the
studio with us thank you it's lovely to
be back all right